today
a jury in minnesota
found former minneapolis police officer
derrick chauvin
guilty on all counts in the murder
of george floyd last may
it was a murder in the full light of day
and it ripped the blinders off for the
whole world to see
the systemic racism the vice president
just referred to
there were systemic reasons as a stain
on our nation's soul
the knee on the neck of justice for
black americans profound fear and trauma
the pain the exhaustion and black and
brown americans experience
every single day the murder of george
floyd
launched the summer a protest we hadn't
seen since the civil rights year in the
60s
protests that unified people of every
race and generation
in peace and with purpose to say enough
enough enough of this senseless killings
today today's verdict
is a step forward i just spoke with the
governor of minnesota
who thanked me for the close work with
his team
i also spoke with george floyd's family
again
a remarkable family of extraordinary
courage
nothing can ever bring their brother
their father back
but this can be a giant step forward in
the march
toward justice in america
let's also be clear that such a verdict
is also
much too rare
for so many people it seems like it took
a unique and extraordinary convergence
of factors
a brave young woman with a smartphone
camera
a crowd that was traumatized traumatized
witnesses
a murder that lasts almost 10 minutes
in broad daylight for ultimately the
whole world to see
officers standing up and testifying
against a fellow officer
instead of just closing ranks
which should be commended
a jury who heard the evidence carried
out their civic duty
in the midst of an extraordinary moment
under extraordinary pressure
for so many it feels like it took
all of that for the judicial system
to deliver a just just basic
accountability
we saw how traumatic and exhausting just
watching the trial was for so many
people
think about it those of you are
listening think about how traumatic it
was for you
you weren't there you didn't know any of
the people
but it was difficult especially for the
witnesses
who had to relive that day
it's a trauma on top
of the fear so many people of color live
with every day
when they go to sleep at night and pray
for the safety of themselves
and their loved ones again
as we saw in this trial from the fellow
police officers who testified
most men and women aware of the badge
serve their communities honorably
but those few who fail to meet that
standard
must be held accountable and they were
today
one was no one should be above the law
and today's verdict sends that message
but it's not enough we can't stop here
in order to deliver real change and
reform
we can and we must do more to reduce the
likelihood that tragedies like this will
ever happen and occur again
to ensure the black and brown people or
anyone
so they don't fear the interactions with
law enforcement
that they don't have to wake up knowing
that they can lose their very life in
the course of just living their life
they don't have to worry about whether
their sons or daughters
will come home after a grocery store run
or just walking down the street or
driving the car or playing in the park
or just sleeping at home
and this takes acknowledging and
confronting head-on
systemic racism and the racial
disparities that exist in policing
and in our criminal justice system more
broadly
you know state and local government and
law enforcement
needs to step up but so does the federal
government
that's why i've appointed the leadership
of the justice department that i have
that is fully committed to restoring
trust between law enforcement and the
community they are
sworn to serve and protect
i have complete confidence in the
attorney general
general garland's leadership and
commitment i've also nominated
two key justice department nominees
vanita gupta
and kristin clark who are eminently
qualified
highly respected lawyers who have spent
their entire careers
fighting to advance racial equity and
justice
bonita and kristen have the experience
and the skill
necessary to advance our
administration's priorities to root out
unconstitutional policing and reform our
criminal justice system
and they deserve to be confirmed
we also need congress to act
george floyd was murdered almost a year
ago
there's meaningful police reform
legislation in his name
you just heard the vice president speak
of it she helped write it
legislation to tackle systemic
misconduct in police departments
to restore trust between law enforcement
and the people they're entrusted to
serve and protect
but it shouldn't take a whole year to
get this done
my conversations with the floyd family i
spoke to them again today
i assure them we're going to continue to
fight for the passage of the jordan
florida justice and policing act
so we can i can sign the law as quickly
as possible
there's more to do finally
it's the work we do every day to change
hearts and minds as well as laws and
policies
that's the work we have to do only then
will full justice and full equality be
delivered to all americans
and that's what i just discussed with
the floyd family
the guilty verdict does not bring back
george but
through the family's pain they're
finding purpose
so george george's legacy will not be
just about his death
but about what we must do in his memory
i also spoke to gianna george loves
george's
young daughter again when i met her last
year i've said this before at george's
funeral
i told her how brave i thought she was
and i sort of knelt down to hold her
hand
i said daddy's looking down on you he's
so proud
he said to me then i'll never forget it
daddy changed the world i told
her this afternoon that he did change
the world
let that be his legacy a legacy of peace
not violence of justice peaceful
expression
of that legacy are inevitable and
appropriate
but violent protest is not and there are
those who will seek to exploit the raw
emotions of the moment
agitators and extremists who have no
interest in social justice
who seek to carry out violence destroy
property fan the flames of hate and
division
will do everything in their power to
stop this country's march toward racial
justice
we can't let them succeed this is a time
for this country to come together
to unite as americans there can never be
any safe harbor for hate in america
i've said it many times the battle for
soul of this nation has been
a constant push and pull for more than
240 years
a tug of war between the american ideal
that we're all created equal in the
harsh reality
that racism has long torn us apart
at our best the american ideal wins out
so we can't leave this moment or look
away thinking our work is done
we have to look at it we have to we've
looked as as we did
for those nine minutes and 29 seconds
we have to listen i can't breathe
i can't breathe
those are george floyd's last words
we can't let those words die with him
we have to keep hearing those words
we must not turn away we can't turn away
we have a chance to begin to change
trajectory
in this country it's my hope and prayer
that we live up to the legacy
may god bless you but may god bless the
george floyd and his family thank you
for taking the time to be here
this can be a moment of significant
change thank you